[Musique]
la mise en place de l'extension du pass
sanitaires prévues pour le 9 août
prochain sous réserve d'une validation
du conseil constitutionnel elle porte
parole du gouvernement qui confirme dans
le même temps la forte augmentation des
cas trop vite dans le pays est l'état
d'urgence sanitaire est d'ailleurs
décrété en guadeloupe à saint martin est
elle sortie après quatre jours en
polynésie française et me bellemare on
s'est exprimé sur les essais nucléaires
entrepris par l'armée française entre
1966 et 1996
le président français a admis une dette
envers le peuple polynésien sont
toutefois présenter des excuses
il a également promis une meilleure
indemnisation pour les victimes de ces
essais nucléaires
[Musique]
et puis rencontre entre diplomates
russes et américains aujourd'hui à
genève le but continuer le dialogue
entamé par joe biden et vladimir poutine
le 16 juin dernier
les relations restent toujours tendues
entre les deux puissances le président
américain a accusé
la russie d'influer sur les élections
une compréhension et une connaissance
erronée de la russie contemporaine
réponse aujourd'hui le kremlin
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france le traditionnel
conseil des ministres avant la pause
estivale s'est tenue ce matin au coeur
des discussions sans surprise la
situation sanitaire
elle se dégrade en guadeloupe à saint
martin et à saint barthélémy où l'état
d'urgence sanitaire est déclarée elle
partout sur le territoire à les
indicateurs sont à la hausse et une
décision importante prise lors de ce
conseil des ministres l entrée en
vigueur de l'extension du pass année
terre elle est prévue pour le 9 août
prochain et je vous propose justement
d'écouter le porte parole du
gouvernement
27000 cas ont été recensés dans la
journée d'hier de coton désormais plus
de 19000 cas par jour en moyenne ses 97
% de plus qu'il ya une semaine
et si cette progression a pu très
légèrement ralentir ces derniers jours
elle reste extrêmement élevé la carte de
france est désormais presque entièrement
rouge et elle est par endroits rouge
écarlate
plus encore que les précédentes la
quatrième vague frappe tout le
territoire le taux d'incidence augmente
fortement partout dans plus de la moitié
des régions il fait plus que doublé
grâce aux vaccins nous pouvons éviter
une forte vague hospitalière au mois
d'août et à la rentrée d'ores et déjà
nous constatons une décorrélation entre
les contaminations et les cas graves qui
nécessitent une hospitalisation
olivier verrons nous le rappelait ce
matin l'impact est deux à trois fois
moins important que lors des vagues
précédentes la corrélation entre nombre
de contaminations et nombre
d'hospitalisations et à ce stade 2 à
foix 2 à 3 fois moins importante que
dans les vagues précédentes
nous le répétons depuis des semaines il
n'y a pas de fatalité avec les gestes
barrière avec nos mesures de contrôle
avec une vaccination rapide et massive
nous pouvons contenir cette quatrième
vague à l'hôpital oui c'est un fait
un fait nouveau nous avons les moyens de
faire reculer l'épidémie
l'augmentation de nombre de quêtes
qu'ovide qui oblige le ministère de
l'éducation nationale a déployé nouvelle
stratégie pour la rentrée prévue dans un
peu plus d'un mois et jean michel blanc
coeur
on a dévoilé les grandes lignes pas de
passes sanitaires pour accéder aux
établissements mais les centres de
vaccination seront installés dans les
collèges et les lycées et les élèves
pourront se faire vacciner avec une
autorisation parentale a pas de
vaccination obligatoire pour les
enseignants en primaire ça ne change pas
fermeture immédiate de classes dès le
premier cas détecté en revanche les cas
contacts suivront à les cours depuis la
maison d'écouté justement à jean-michel
bancaire en primaire lorsqu'il y aura un
cas de contamination dans une classe on
fermera dans l'enseignement secondaire
ce seront les élèves non vaccinés qui
seront évincés
mais pas les élèves vaccinés notre
objectif n'est pas d'appliquer le pass
sanitaire en milieu scolaire ou
universitaire
les élèves de l'école primaire seront
testés plus souvent au moins 600 mille
tests salivaires par semaine seront
effectués direction tokyo maintenant au
japon où se déroulent les jeux les jeux
olympiques d'été la capitale japonaise a
enregistré l ce mercredi plus de 3000
nouveaux 4 kovy 19
un record pour la seconde journée
consécutive de quoi inquiéter les
habitants qui sont nombreux à critiquer
la gestion de la pandémie par le
gouvernement
françois tessier beach dans le quartier
animé de shibuya les tokyoïtes font part
de leur inquiétude
je suis assez inquiète quand je suis
dans ma vie quotidienne je ne sais pas
qui est infecté 3177 nouveaux cas de
kobe 19 ont été enregistrées ce mercredi
un record absolu pour la capitale
japonaise qui dépasse pour la première
fois de la pandémie les 3000 infection
une seule journée pour les habitants
très critique sur la gestion de la
pandémie par le gouvernement difficile
de ne pas faire le lien avec les
dizaines de milliers de visiteurs
autorisés à entrer dans le pays à
l'occasion des jeux olympiques jo
d'antan en ce moment jeux olympiques on
joue au baseball ont fait du judo et les
athlètes gagnent des médailles d'or
en voyant cela on se dit que c'est une
bonne idée d'organiser les jeux
olympiques mais ensuite il faut penser
au personnel médical
je pense que le gouvernement ne ressent
pas la gravité de la situation et qu'il
se concentre uniquement sur les jeux
olympiques
un lien de cause à effet contesté par
les autorités japonaises
d'autres feux ceux qui sont venus au
japon pour les jeux olympiques sont dans
une bulle
ils ne se mélangent pas vraiment avec le
grand public japonais
il ya quelques cas qui ont été testés
positifs avec les tests pcr mais ils ont
été isolés et je pense que le comité
d'organisation olympique s'en occupe
assez bien faire l'erreur concernant la
vaccination si le gouvernement avait
promis un pays 100% immunisés avec la
tenue des jeux olympiques c'est
seulement 26 % des japonais qui sont
aujourd'hui pleinement vacciner pour les
autorités il est donc primordial de
convaincre les jeunes générations de se
faire vacciner responsable selon
certains experts de la flambée actuelle
des infections même si nous avons
ralenti un peu la vaccination ça va nous
devons plutôt nous adresser aux jeunes
pour qu'ils comprennent qu'il est
nécessaire de se faire vacciner
j'envoie donc un message au maire ne
vous préoccupez pas de la vitesse de la
vaccination mais tendait la main aux
jeunes de votre ville est convaincu que
c'est une bonne idée de se faire
vacciner
la gouverneur de tokyo a de son côté
invité la population à suivre les
mesures et à rester chez elle autant que
possible pour éviter la propagation du
virus
la capitale nippone et d'ailleurs
jusqu'à la fin des jeux olympiques sous
le coup de son quatrième état d'urgence
sanitaire
mais à l inverse de nombreux pays le
japon ne prévoit pas de sanctions pour
les contrevenants
le gouvernement comptant essentiellement
sur la bonne volonté des citoyens
on reste dans le domaine de la santé
avec cette information révélée récemment
près de la moitié des pharmacies
françaises transmettent les données
personnelles de leurs clients à une
entreprise américaine pathologie
traitement et d'autres encore sont
envoyés via nos cartes vitale haïti via
le tout sans en avertir les patients une
collecte d'informations qui se fait le
plus souvent contre rémunération les
explications de david khelifa ans étant
périlleux pour nos libertés
individuelles savoir que notre vie
privée peut être commercialisée via
notre santé n'a rien de rassurant
et pourtant c'est bien le cas nous
sommes le 20 mai 2021 nos confrères de
france 2 dans le cadre de l'émission
cash investigations révèlent un scandale
d'état
on peut l'appeler comme ça plus de la
moitié des pharmacies françaises
transmettre nos informations de santé à
la société américaine il vient plus gros
revendeurs de données médicales au monde
concrètement ces données regroupe votre
numéro de sécurité sociale votre année
de naissance votre prénom ainsi que
votre sexe et surtout les données dites
de délivrance c'est à dire toutes les
informations que contient votre
ordonnance et donc les pathologies dont
vous êtes possiblement atteint ajoutez à
ça les informations concernant votre
médecin votre pharmacie et certains
paramètres géographique le tout contre
la modique somme 6 euros par mois
directement financé par l'entreprise
il vient on le fait essentiellement pour
l'industrie de la santé pour les
autorités qu'elles soient françaises ou
européennes
ce serait dans des conditions très
particulières si on le faisait pour des
compagnies d'assurance pour des
fondations à but de prévention par
exemple ce qui n'est pas arrivé pour
l'instant sur ce point la cnil le
gendarme numérique français en matière
de données personnelles avait donné son
aval en 2018
mais du côté des politiques à la suite
de la diffusion de cette émission on
s'interroge
adrien taquet secrétaire d'état a chargé
de la protection de l'enfance a tenté de
rassurer héberge sur ses serveurs un
certain nombre de données entièrement
pseudo mise pseudonyme ise premier point
l'entreprise n'a bien sûr jamais
se donner aux mises et ceux de nos mises
et ceux de miser
se donne aux mises et on a compris
poursuivez monsieur le président
l'entreprise n'a pas d'adressé l'atrice
jamais accès jamais accès à l'identité
du patient ces données permettent de
mener des études d'intérêt public qui
vise par exemple l'évaluation de la
bonne utilisation du médicament ce
processus et notamment son niveau de
sécurité est parfaitement conforme très
rarement à ce que vous laissiez entendre
à la déclaration faite à la cnil qui
prévoit que ces données sont traitées en
interne ne sont pas transmises à des
tiers
le lapsus est révélateur à vous de vous
faire votre propre opinion
quoi qu'il en soit à l'argumentaire de
l'exécutif concernant l anonymisation de
ces données est correct sauf que cette
fameuse déclaration faite par la cnil
souligne un point important concernant
l'intérêt public
en france l'utilisation d'informations
médicales est strictement encadré
la cnil ne peut autoriser un tel
entrepôt de données que s'il présente
une finalité d'intérêt public
la cnil considère que la poursuite d'un
intérêt public est conciliable avec la
poursuite d'un intérêt commercial
le doute est donc permis plus qu'un
simple numéro de sécurité sociale même
se donner mise et permet d'accéder à
votre parcours de santé votre âge votre
sexe et à votre département
autrement dit il est très facile de
retrouver votre identité à des fins
commerciales
alors l'inquiétude est permise mais vous
pouvez éviter ça en demandant l'arrêt de
la collecte de ces données seulement
pour ça il faut en être informé c'est
même obligatoire pour les pharmacies qui
ont recours à ce protocole l'officine en
question doit informer le patient à
travers une affichette mais très peu
d'entre elles respectent cette charte
ce qui automatiquement les protège on a
été mis en défaut sur les affiches
prévenant de cette extraction de données
et c'est vrai qu'elle n'était pas
souvent là mais je doute de leur
efficacité
personne ne regarde les affiches dans
les pharmacies une institution se doit
d'inspecter ces officines et
possiblement les sanctionner la cnil
mais ce domaine est bien trop basse et
même en cas d'intervention le risque est
faible pour les pharmacies comme dit le
proverbe on n'est jamais si bien servi
que par soi même surtout quand il s'agit
de notre vie privée
à vous de juger
paris ici appelle à la nomination rapide
d'un premier ministre et d'un
gouvernement aux tunisie trois jours
après le coup de force du président kaïs
sayed el le calme est revenu dans le
pays
la formation islamiste principal parti
au parlement ennahda demandent des
élections législatives et présidentielle
anticipées ont fait le point justement
sur la situation avec notre reporter sur
place ben hassen chébili alors que le
président de la république maintient sa
feuille de route vers un changement
radical du système politique
les limogeages se poursuivre tout comme
les arrestations et les ouvertures
denquête après une réunion au palais de
carthage entre le président sayed et de
hauts responsables
la question du financement des partis
politiques et des associations a été
évoquée il n'en fallait pas moins pour
que la justice tunisienne ouvrait une
enquête contre le parti islamiste
ennahda et son allié taleb tonus le
parti de nabil karoui
l'ancien candidat à la présidentielle de
2010 9 ainsi que la formation itunes
pour une affaire de financements
étrangers de leurs campagnes électorales
de 2019
une enquête du pôle judiciaire et
financier sur le financement étranger et
l'acceptation de dons dont la source est
inconnue lors de la campagne électorale
de 2019 selon le porte parole du parquet
tunisien
une annonce qui intervient trois jours
après la suspension du parlement pour
une durée de 30 jours et le limogeage du
premier ministre hichem et chichi par le
président taille side qui s'est octroyé
le pouvoir exécutif
en attendant la nomination d'un prochain
gouvernement et d'un nouveau premier
ministre
une rencontre substantielle pour
washington pragmatique pour moscou les
diplomates des deux puissances
elles se sont rencontrées aujourd'hui à
genève de nombreux dossiers sensibles
étaient sur la table notamment à la
question des armes nucléaires une
rencontre qui intervient au lendemain de
nouvelles accusations de la part de joe
biden qui reproche à la russie de
chercher à perturber l et législatives
américaines de 2022
le kremlin a répondu dans la journée la
correspondance à moscou devait radwane
la russie n'est jamais intervenu dans
les processus électoraux des états unis
a déclaré le porte parole du kremlin
dmitri peskov
selon lui de nombreuses enquêtes menées
aux états unis ont déjà confirmé ce fait
je vous propose d'écouter la russie
n'est jamais intervenu dans les
processus électoraux des états unis les
résultats de nombreuses enquêtes qui ont
eu lieu en amérique confirme que la
russie n'est jamais intervenu c'est la
première chose ne fait aucun doute que
la russie n'intervient pas et n'a pas la
moindre intention d'un carillon à les
processus et les kills roulage autres
pays
je pense que cette interrogation fait
partie des dix jeunes ont réalisé par
des experts et qui ont été présentées au
président américain dmitri peskov a
également souligné qu'il ne fallait pas
considérer le sommet de genève comme une
sorte de ce après lequel la russie et
les etats unis sont entrés dans l'ère de
la coopération et du partenariat
écoutez il ne faut pas se bercer
d'illusions superflu est exagéré
l'esprit de genève
vu qu il ya eu des négociations très
directe utile et constructive aux
billets directs qui ont clairement fait
ressortir les points sur lesquels nous
avons de graves déjà d'accord le
résultat positif de 6 négociation
résident la compréhension de la
nécessité d'engager des contacts sur un
certain nombre de questions y
cybersécurité stabilité stratégique et
peut-être d'autres
en ce qui concerne la cyber sécurité la
stabilité stratégique les contacts sont
en cours et c'est quelque chose de
positif et tout voir en rose est
considérée gnl comme une sorte de seuil
après lequel nous serions d'ores et déjà
entrés dans l'ère du partenariat et de
la coopération
ce ne serait pas raisonnable le porte
parole du kremlin a également regretté
que la russie les états unis n'est pas
de relation de partenariat il a ajouté
que les états unis peuvent être
qualifiées d' interlocuteur ou
d'adversaires aux états unis maintenant
la justice condamne à quarante cinq mois
de prison un ancien analyste des
services de renseignement américain en
fonctions en afghanistan entre 2011 et
2012 on reproche à daniel elle est
d'avoir a transmis à la presse en 2015
des informations sur un programme
militaire secret d'assassinats ciblés
par drones
le tout alors que barack obama était
président des états unis
on en parle justement avec notre
correspondant à washington tom abonnés à
thomas bonsoir alors que faut-il retenir
de cette affaire
eh bien vous l'avez dit daniel est un
ancien analyste au sein de la msa
notamment en afghanistan entre 2011 et
2012 puis il a rejoint en 2014 le angie
et le renseignement géospatial il a donc
participé au cours de sa carrière à ses
frappes de drones il a aussi eu accès à
des documents classifiés et il a donc
transmis une partie de ces documents en
2015 au site
zinn intercepte ce qui a amené à la
publication d'un dossier qu'on a
présentée comme les deux drones papers
pardon il s'agissait en réalité de
présenter les dessous d'un programme
d'exécution par drones menées par les
états unis pendant plusieurs années dans
des pays tels que le yémen l'afghanistan
ou encore la somalie des révélations qui
avait soulevé un certain nombre de
questions à l'époque d'abord certaines
de ces opérations étaient menées hors
zone de guerre déclarée par les états
unis n'y avait pas de traduction en
justice pour les cibles de ces attaques
par drones le choix d'ailleurs de ses
cibles a lui aussi posé question et puis
il y avait évidemment la question des
dommages collatéraux provoqués par ces
frappes de drones notamment auprès des
populations civiles
alors lors du procès qui s'est déroulé
hier la défense de daniel et il a mis en
avant le fait que cet ancien analyste
voulait informer le public américain de
ces manoeuvres qui était méconnu du
grand public jusqu'à lors il avait
plaidé coupable lors du procès il a donc
été reconnu coupable par la justice
américaine dans le cadre de l'espionage
act
il a été condamné à quarante cinq mois
de prison une condamnation qui a fait
vivement réagir un certain nombre
d'associations d'observateurs écouté par
exemple ces deux anciens
de la cia et de l'armée américaine en
tant qu'individus dénonçant publiquement
ce programme de drone depuis près d'une
décennie
je trouve cela très étrange que des
personnes consciencieuses qui
participent à ce programme
essayez de pointe et notre
responsabilité dans les crimes de guerre
évident est flagrant que nous commettons
soient punis il semble que ces gens sont
punis pour l'exemple et cela me trouble
vraiment surtout si les états unis sont
censés être ce grand pays combattant
pour la liberté donnée pour moi le juste
verdict aurait été que le juge qu'il son
siège lui serre la main pour le
remercier des services rendus à la
nation et le laisse rentrer chez lui
auprès de sa famille je ne pensais pas
qu'il méritait une peine de prison
quelle qu'elle soit
car il a révélé un crime commis par le
gouvernement américain ce crime
le meurtre de civils innocents cette
affaire de daniel elle relance le débat
au sur les lanceurs d'alert qui sont
toujours pris pour cibles aux états unis
notamment donc par la justice évidemment
cette affaire nous rappelle d'autres
affaires précédentes évidemment celle
d'edouard snowdon ou encore plus
récemment celle de julian assange qui
est lui aussi on le rappelle son coût de
ces fameux de ce fameux espionage act
s'il venait à être extradé aux états
unis merci beaucoup thomas bonnet
correspondant donc à washington par arte
france
retour en france maintenant avec cette
visite d' emmanuel macron polynésie
française pas d' excuses au sujet des
essais nucléaires mais le président a
reconnu une dette de l'état entre 1966
et 1996 193 essais nucléaires ont été
effectués dans l'archipel à causant de
nombreuses victimes je vous propose
d'écouter ajustements à ce sujet
emmanuel macron je veux ici vous dire
que la nation a une dette à l'égard de
la polynésie française cette dette est
le fait d'avoir en effet abrité ces
essais et en particulier les essais
nucléaires entre 66 et 74 dont on ne
peut absolument pas dire qu'ils étaient
proches non c'est que trop longtemps
l'état a préféré garder le silence sur
ce passé c'est trente années d'explosion
successives
ce que je veux briser aujourd'hui c'est
ce silence pour faire entendre justement
toute la vérité pour qu'elle soit
partagée pour que tout le monde puisse
savoir exactement ce qui a été fait ce
qui était su alors est ce qui est sûr
aujourd'hui tout j'assume
et je veux la vérité et la transparence
avec vous mais on continue de parler de
cette visite du chef de l'état en
polynésie française avec notre invité à
mon état hébreu or some député gauche
démocrate et républicaine de polynésie
française bonjour muay thaï brothers ce
merci d'être avec nous ce soir sur arte
france alors le président a évoqué une
dette de la france à l'égard de la
polynésie
c'est ce que vous attendiez non pas du
tout son service l'évocation de cette
dette a déjà été fait à l'époque par le
président chirac donc là rien de nouveau
sous le soleil
en revanche ce que nous attendions ce
que les polynésiens attendait c'est
cette demande de pardon qui visiblement
on n'est toujours pas à l'ordre du jour
justement j'avais j'avais vous le dira
pas d'excusés de la part d'un des
manuels macron au nom de la france
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous
ressentez justement après cette non
excuses je le sent beaucoup de déception
et j'ai quand même le sentiment que ces
quatre jours passés par emmanuel macron
polisy viser plus à lancer sa campagne
des présidentielles qu'à réellement
venir rencontrer l'âme des polynésiens
quand bien même les mots utilisés et et
lyrique théâtraux le contenu et au final
est assez creux le président a également
dit vouloir la vérité la transparence
sur surtout ses essais nucléaires à des
archives vont être ouvertes qu'est ce
que vous attendez justement l'ouverture
de ses archives
écoutez les archives
encore faut-il savoir de quelles
archives repart déjà les archives on va
dire les petits contiendrait le plus
d'informations utiles ne seront pas
ouvertes c'est ce que c'est ce qui est
classé comme archive prend différentes
qu'est ce que c'est qu'une archives
proliférante par exemple c'est
l'emplacement des puits de tir d essai
souterrain et bien comme nous n'aurons
jamais accès à ces archives là nous ne
serons jamais quel est le degré de
radioactivité à l'endroit de ses puits
de tir aujourd'hui qu'elle est
comment vous vivez ça vous justement en
polynésie française cette visite du
président justement et le fait qu'il ne
s'excuse toujours pas au nom de la
france
nous nous trouvons cette visite un peu
déplacé alors la france et l'hexagone
est confronté à de réels problèmes de
graves problèmes je crains que le
président d'accor à son arrivée à paris
puisqu'il est parti hier soir de
prévisions au delà du choc thermique
soit confronté à d' autres shops est ce
que vous avez pu vous rencontrer le
président emmanuel macron ou où
certaines de vos de vos connaissances et
est-ce que vous lui avez parlé justement
deux de ses excuses que les polynésiens
attendent
vous savez nous avons exprimé le souhait
que une réunion puisse se tenir ici avec
tous ceux qui ont refusé de participer à
la table ronde qui a été organisée à
paris
ce choix n'a pas été entendue donc le
plaisir n'accord n'a pas souhaité
rencontrer on va dire d'autres voies que
celles qui ont chanté ses louanges
le président s'est ainsi engagé à la
dépollution des sites encore atteint par
l'armée est ce que ces zones sont
justement nombreuses en polynésie alors
les zones polluées sont nombreuses mais
attention à ce qui a été dit le
président on ne sait absolument pas
engagé à dépolluer il s'est simplement
engagé à retirer les équipements qui ont
été laissés sur place
c'est à vrai dire assez insidieux
puisque il s'agit en fait pour l'état
d'effacer les traces de ces essais
nucléaires et non pas de réellement
dépolluer ce sont des vieux hangar ce
sont des bunkers
ce sont des des engins qui vont être
enlevés mais la pollution réelle elle
est au fond de ces 2 quid qui font plus
d'un kilomètre de profondeur à mon
endroit
la pollution réelle elle est au fond du
lagon moudre sur le banc de colette du
plutonium est encore le déposer
merci
beaucoup moins état et brodeur sommes
d'avoir été avec nous aujourd'hui sur
arte france rappelle que vous êtes
député gauche démocrate et républicaine
de polynésie française merci à vous
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci à
vous d'avoir suivi prochain point sur
l'actualité ce sera dans un peu plus de
38 minutes rester avec nous sur arte
france a ce talent
bon
[Musique]
la grande bretagne a donc eu cinq ans
pour se préparer cinq ans de psychodrame
ça contre négociations politiques
est-ce qu'elle était prête je 31
décembre pour redevenir une île réponse
par du moment où le royaume uni avait
décidé de quitter l'union européenne il
ne pouvait plus continuer de bénéficier
de ses droits équivalents à si vous êtes
dans l'europe pas dans l'europe
vis-à-vis des 27 états autres c'est
juste quelque chose d'inconcevable
l'angleterre vab à perdre gros là nos
amis britanniques